welcome back everyone this is going to
be my venom 2 trailer video we finally
got our first official look at the
carnage symbiote there's a whole bunch
of easter eggs here and some spider-man
easter eggs so we'll break it all down
if you're brand new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos
there is a lot of spider-man related
movies coming in the next couple years
also explain some of the connection
between the events of venom 2 because
there's some easter eggs connecting it
to the morbius movie which is meant to
be a direct spin-off of the venom
franchise and connecting that to tom
holland's spider-man 3 no way home you
also notice that on page 2 here it reads
avengers in the title so they're clearly
trying to cross this over with the mcu
it's been a couple years since the
events of the last film they start the
trailer inside eddie's apartment it's
the same apartment from the first venom
film so he hasn't moved or anything but
they show you what it's been like living
with the carnage symbiote for the last
couple of years and it's sort of like
they've turned into this weird couple
and they try to play it for a little bit
of comedy like just everything is all
over the place is crazy it looks like a
nightmare you can see the symbiote has
basically been trying to take care of
everything for him and is driving him
crazy and even though it doesn't really
look particularly appetizing it does
manage to cook him breakfast as messily
as possible the symbiote is kind of like
a goat it could digest anything
inorganic matter he could eat a tin can
like a goat and it would still be able
to digest it that's why they have all
the jokes about not eating people like
literally they open on that joke in his
apartment while it's cooking breakfast
no eating people the song that's playing
is that louis armstrong ella fitzgerald
song let's call the whole thing off and
that's just a metaphor about their
relationship before they start with a
different song one is the loneliest
number about a couple of the different
relationships during the trailer like
there's the idea of the implied
relationship between the carnage
symbiote and the venom symbiote they
also used that loneliest number song to
play on his relationship with anne wang
and play on cletus cassidy's
relationship with shriek his girlfriend
from the comics in the maximum carnage
storyline which they're actually basing
most of the movie on they're mixing a
couple different carnage and venom
stories from the spider-man comics so
they're mixing the maximum carnage
storyline with his origin story which
are completely separate in the comics i
don't know how i feel about the venom
symbiote singing that song but it does a
good job of showing you how they've
changed the way they've tuned the venom
voice so the venom voice is actually
just tom hardy's voice processed in a
very different way it's the exact same
way they're going to be doing the
carnage voice as well but you don't hear
the carnage voice you only see carnage
and then you hear cletus cassidy
speaking when he's not carnage but
throughout the trailer you see him
reading the daily bugles website which
is our first big spider-man easter egg
and it probably has something to do with
the article that the detective is
reading in the separate scene in the
print version of the daily bugle now the
other really important easter egg here
for the spider-man movies isn't just for
the tom hall and spider-man it's
actually for toby maguire spider-man
because the daily bugle logo on this
here is the same logo from the toby
maguire spider-man movies i'll explain
what kevin feige said about crossing
those characters over in a second he
talked about tom holland jumping
cinematic universes like he jumps the
multiverse we also have the idea that
spider-man 3 no way home is
incorporating some spider-verse
multiverse elements in the film so that
could be one of the ways they explain
all these inconsistencies because it
seems like venom 2 wants to make a lot
of references to the sony spider-man
movies including the andrew garfield
amazing spider-man films because we have
the ravencroft institute which was
featured heavily during the amazing
spider-man 2 when they were setting up
the sinister six they brought back mrs
chen and they've explained that she
knows all about what's going on with the
venom symbiote they have the twist on
the joke from the first venom movie
trailer where they had him eating that
guy who was actually trying to hold the
convenience store up only this time
apparently the whole idea is that in the
couple years since the events of the
first film he's been protecting her and
she's been paying him back quote paying
the symbiote back for protecting her in
exchange for some special chocolate
which apparently is late in the venom
symbiote is furious about and wants to
eat her no no we can't eat mrs chen wait
what what are you talking about they
jump back and forth between a couple
prisons in the film you have the state
penitentiary the cletus cassidy was
being held in during the first film he's
still there he's on death row but then
they also flash with shriek his
girlfriend who's in new york city inside
the ravencroft institute on the other
side of the country also new york city
kind of in the area where spider-man is
so you can see they're slowly moving the
plot of venom 2 to the new york city
area to put him in proximity with the
spider-man character and even though you
don't see it during the events of the
trailer they kind of imply that the
carnage symbiote makes its way to new
york city to try and free her after it
escapes from prison the director of this
movie is andy circus he actually did
some commentary clarifying that during
the events of this film the characters
are unaware that spider-man himself
exists this is the clip of him talking
about that obviously there are links
between venom and spider spider-man in
the marvel universe and the spider-man
story but in this you know we're
treating this very much as
it hits his own world the venom story is
his own world there are nods and and
little moments that that you just like
this newspaper the daily bugle of course
but on on the whole he's unaware they
are unaware at this point of other
characters like spider-man that's that's
that's the way we've chosen to play this
particular episode of the of the of the
movie but well we'll wait and see we'll
see what what little uh things you can
pick out of it you see that eddie is
still going to see cletus cassidy the
way they explain it during the trailer
is that article about the hidden victims
of cletus cassidy apparently trying to
find all these hidden bodies that the
authorities never found when they
initially captured him but they never
fully explained how the carnage symbiote
is created where it comes from during
the film i'm assuming for now without
more footage that it's just based on the
comic book explainer that it spawns from
the venom symbiote and at some point
during some of their meetings when he's
in the prison it spawns eddie doesn't
realize what's going on then the carnage
symbiote just bonds to the first thing
that it finds which happens to be cletus
cassidy that's basically what happened
in the comic book version only in the
comic book version eddie brock was
inside the prison cell with cletus they
were cellmates and when the venom
symbiote came to break eddie out of
prison the offspring bonded with cletus
cassidy and you have the carnage
symbiote then cletus cassidy narrates
the rest of the trailer talking about
their relationship while they sort of
intercut with the other relationships
during the film like anne weighing in
the shriek character but we have to say
how they mercifully cut his hair i am so
happy that they got rid of that weird
wig from the first venom movie they
intercut with venom taking out more
criminals on the streets remember the
bargain that he made with it during the
events of the first film he said we're
only going to hurt bad people cletus
talks about them leaving people behind
as they intercut with the anne weighing
footage obviously she's a big part of
this film she made some comments about
doing more lady venom scenes during this
film so she might also get the symbiote
again briefly during the events of the
film they don't explain too much of
what's going on with shriek but the
whole idea is that ravencroft is a place
where they put the criminally insane and
some super villains with special powers
which it seems like shriek does have her
special powers from the comics it's
basically like a banshee sonic scream if
you haven't read the maximum carnage
storyline shriek just teams up with the
carnage symbiote during that now these
scenes are from new york city so he
climbs up on that building next to the
gargoyle looks out over it they do this
big white city shot they've moved the
plot to new york city by this point in
the film
very overt twist on a spider-man
reference here so you have cletus
cassidy who seems like he's writing a
note to send to eddie brock the note
that he's actually reading when the
symbiote is cooking him breakfast
earlier in the trailer it's got the same
red ink on it so it just seems like he's
sending eddie mail but you also see the
red spider climb up and he smashes it
just meant to be a clever reference to
spider-man's classic spider bite origin
story but unless they get really twisty
though i don't think his origin story
has anything to do with any kind of
spider bite i still think it's going to
be a twist on the classic carnage
storyline from the comics you could also
look at him smashing the spider as a
reference to him fighting spider-man
eventually too i think the whole idea is
they would love for venom and spider-man
tom hall and spider-man to team up and
fight carnage in a future film because
that is basically what the maximum
carnage storyline is and probably one of
the reasons why they save that title for
one of the movies like why they call
this movie let there be carnage instead
of just calling it maximum carnage we
see him on death row they're getting
ready to execute him and as they start
to pump him full of the drugs that are
basically going to kill him the carnage
symbiote just explodes out of his body
so at this point in the film he's
already gotten the symbiote we just
don't see that happen and he talks about
becoming chaos which also you could
think of as a reference for that classic
carnage storyline with cathone the god
of chaos although i don't think they're
even getting close to cosmic during this
film and that's a very cosmic carnage
story there's this whole idea that
there's a prophecy about carnage inside
the dark hole they just featured the
darkhold inside the one division series
because there's a prophecy about scarlet
witch in it scarlet witch is crossing
over into doctor strange 2 multiverse of
madness in doctor strange 2 the movie is
coming out right after spider-man 3 no
way home there's also supposed to be
some crossover elements with spider-man
inside the morbius movie and now the
morbius movie has been rescheduled and
it's coming out just a couple weeks
after spider-man 3 no way home comes out
in theaters so towards the end of the
year there's going to be a lot of
spider-man related stuff happening now
this scene of the building burning down
seems like a completely different place
than we've seen before so this might be
the orphanage where carnage grew up as a
child or where cletus cassidy grew up as
a child because a little while later in
the trailer there's a scene of it not
burned down like completely whole and
you see the carnage symbiote all over it
attacking these cards i believe this
scene is also supposed to be in the new
york city area so it's happening later
in the film obviously after carnage
travels to new york city this is venom
inside new york city swinging around the
buildings using the symbiote very much
like spider-man would do they show you
eddie going to meet with this detective
character who seems like he's a pretty
big person during the film probably just
another person who's trying to pursue
cletus cassidy seems like he's really
upset about the idea that he did not
discover a bunch of bodies that cletus
apparently buried somewhere and it seems
like the venom symbiote doesn't like him
either like it's trying to eat him and
he has to stop it this footage of the
cell block just seems like it's the cell
block where cletus was being held and
it's in the middle of his big prison
break you guys can let me know what you
think about the look of the carnage
symbiote during the film it looks like
they're trying to base it on some of the
more recent comic book designs but
they're trying to make it as red as
possible without actually making it deep
saturated red like they want it to look
as different from the venom symbiote as
possible while still making it look kind
of like the venom symbiote it looks like
this is happening in some sort of
industrial park probably before a big
fight scene with the venom symbiote then
they end the trailer with a sort of
post-credit scene like the trailer has
its own post-credits scene with carnage
inside the church in front of that
stained glass window so obviously
there's a big church fight scene which
is a cool reference to the comic book
origin of venom which they obviously
changed during the events of the first
film because of all these toby easter
eggs during the film with the daily
bugle kind of makes you think of the
tobey maguire spider-man 3 movie where
they did try to do a comic book accurate
version of venom's origin story with the
church bells very biblical putting it in
front of this church in the stained
glass window that also kind of gets into
the prophecy and the dark hold about
carnage being the end of the world this
big prophecy about how he's going to
bring about this great destruction i
know a lot of people are wondering if
they're ever going to get to knowl the
god of the symbiotes in any of these
venom movies that would be like their
version of avengers infinity war and
avengers end game i think sony would
love to build up to a cosmic story that
big but i have no idea if they're gonna
get there and i think right now they're
mostly just focused on crossing over tom
hall and spider-man with the venom
franchise then if the rumors are to be
believed more live-action spider-verse
action because you have all the rumors
about tobey mcguire and andrew garfield
coming back as their versions of
spider-man but just a big reminder the
movie is coming out september 23rd
couple months before spider-man 3 no way
home so we'll see what other easter eggs
they have in trailers later this summer
there'll be more trailers in the next
couple of months but everybody just let
me know if you spotted any easter eggs
in the trailer that i didn't talk about
during the video obviously because of
all the implied spider-man easter eggs
during the morbius trailer and morbius
was originally supposed to come before
venom 2. i think we're all expecting
some sort of legit tom holland cameo
scene like a post-credit scene
explaining how he eventually crosses
over there was also the easter egg from
the morbius movie with the daily bugle
article same version of the daily bugle
because it's the same logo which says
where is spider-man but this is supposed
to happen during the morbius movie not
venom 2. hopefully in the next morbius
trailer they'll have more overt
spider-man references that'll kind of
clarify what's going on with their
spider-man easter eggs and we will get a
brand new spider-man 3 no way home
trailer sometime really soon too of
course i'll do videos for everything we
also have the loki episodes that are
coming up that'll be the next big series
that i'll be doing videos for so make
sure you have alerts enabled so you
don't miss any of those episodes while
you wait for everything click here for
my morbius trailer easter eggs and click
here for my brand new marvel what if
trailer and learn all about the
multiverse avengers team that they're
putting together on that show thank you
so much for watching everyone stay safe
and i'll see you guys tonight